sony they have just released the
official poster for spiderman no way
home after waiting for such a long time
for anything from sony it's kind of
hilarious that we're all super excited
for a poster but we are and it's finally
here now this is the one that we did see
on the bus this is the leaked photo of
the poster that we saw a couple of days
ago but now we have a closer look at
this and it actually reveals a couple of
villains including the green goblin our
first look at the green goblin and i
want to dive into it but a reminder for
the spider-man fans we are giving away a
spider-man action figure to enter just
subscribe to my channel and cosmic
culture and leave some comments on some
videos alright so like i said this does
indeed reveal a few villains obviously
we know doc awk we've seen this that's
the biggest part that we've been able to
make out of this poster and i will say
it isn't 100
the same poster that we saw leaked on
the buses the ones on the buses had a
cityscape in the background possibly the
mirror dimension this one does not have
that this one is actually just in the
sky and i like the fact that it's in the
sky because if you look to the right of
spider-man flying in the air is the
green goblin now i love how they make
the green goblin really really far away
they have now officially revealed the
green goblin and they try to put him far
away so we can't see but we can make it
out that this is indeed willem dafoe's
green goblin costume from the very first
spider-man film he's wearing the helmet
it looks to be the same exact helmet the
suit looks to be exactly the same we can
tell right here this is willem the foe's
green goblin but what's funny here is
that they're really trying to not show
us that it's willem dafoe's green goblin
they even put it far in the back so we
really have to look super hard to make
out the costume they really are trying
to keep that a secret they've only
showed alfred molina but they are trying
to keep the fact that willem dafoe
thomas hayden church and jamie foxx are
returning from their universes into this
movie that's why the green goblin and
the glider are so far away in the
background and that's also why we only
see
lightning from electro but notice it's
not normal white lightning it's the
yellow type of lightning which is
actually comic accurate electro so
perhaps you're going to go for a more
comic accurate look here with electro
after all a lot of people really did not
like amazing spider-man 2. so that could
be a reason for them to go to this more
comic accurate route with him now of
course if you notice something in the
back that kind of looks like a smoke
trail it is indeed a sand trail if you
look at the trail start way in the
background it goes in a very peculiar
pattern and it goes right to spider-man
this of course is sandman and i just
find it really really hilarious that
they're not showing us these villains
they're trying to keep it a secret
overall this poster is okay not gonna
lie it definitely was not worth the hype
but i definitely thought it was going to
be something different now some people
have been saying that they can spot
lizard in the bottom right but i don't
see it i think that's a bit of a stretch
i do however see something in the bottom
left corner that does look an awful lot
like mephisto now i'm only partially
kidding as a lot of people do seem to
think that doctor strange could perhaps
be mephisto especially if you consider
the comic story lines but i do not think
this is mephisto i just think it's
something burning some debris of
something sadly i think the mephisto
theories are dying out at this point we
had a good run though but this is the
poster it's better than i thought it
would be because it does show us green
goblin wearing his original suit from
spider-man 1. and that to me really
makes this yes the poster isn't that
exciting but to see the green goblin
there is awesome but let me know what
you think about this in the comments
down below don't forget to follow me on
twitter i was posting about the poster
releasing a lot today so if you want to
stay up to date on everything you can
follow me on twitter and instagram don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
for the giveaway and as always thank you
all so much for watching woof
you